the taping of the show The Bucket List
special wow wow wow it's coming up
pretty exciting a couple days away not
including all the people who I flew out
to just be here um it's a
$85,000 shoot in the theater just
shooting in the theater is that typical
like do most specials cost somewhere
around there uh I know that on the night
of the shoot for the gnarly special it
was like
125,000 um and that uh that you know
what it actually might include all the
post production I think that's to get to
the deliverables so it's 185,000 for
shooting it and all of the uh post-
production editing now does a does a
percentage of that go to The Venue as
well or is it that I'm sure it covers
all expenses yeah there's a little bit
of a fee um for like you pay you pay a
certain amount to a theater to rent the
theater in order to do the show and you
definitely pay more to the theater to be
able to film The Show for a special MH
but dude like I'm so ready for this man
and thanks to this guy right here the
gorgeous Paul brisy I mean like
we've just we've
tirelessly studied it workshopped it
come up with every little option like oh
let's try this let's try that and uh man
I just I'm really excited about it yeah
it's been so fun like tweaking on [__]
and then cuz you get like the next night
you can just try the new way and it's
like oh that didn't work okay let's try
something new or something so it's it's
like pretty immediate results you get to
see every piece of this project I mean
dude what we spend on the opening
sequence with the
helicopter like 70 to 90 Jes Way D way
more than that really I think so I
thought I thought that was over over
$100,000 a day I need to double check
but I I mean the helicopter was a lot
yeah I mean dude everything was a lot
that's the most though right of all the
bits the helicopter for sure yeah the
taping of of the show is the most then
the
helicopter um was was skyjacking
expensive no the sectomy Olympics was
certainly expensive yeah cuz that was
all we had to fly everybody out there um
but I mean whatever it's just like and
dude the production
design do I do I say on this what the
production design is
if you want yeah give a little tease of
it sure because this is coming out
before May yeah do it dude okay Lux is
the production designer I told her that
I think the most masterful
badass comedy special that I've seen in
a long time was Jew by AR shafir and and
one of the most impressive things about
it was that uh he performed in front of
like hundreds maybe a thousand and lit
candles I was just like dude it was so
ambitious it was so red like how do I do
something like that with the production
design my first thought because uh you
know it's sort of a of a love story and
and the bucket list items like the this
it's the show is a story about how me
doing all the things on the on my bucket
list like impacted my relationship
mostly
negatively um so I thought like roses
but roses would just look dumb and then
luck says well dude it's a multimedia
show like uh bringing together you know
your your video production and your live
performance so why not have like a
mountain like a wall of television sets
like old school TVs old school TVs I'm
like oh my God that's so genius so she's
literally she came up with the idea she
found hundreds of old old school TV sets
from the 80s and 90s um a lot of garage
sales she's been going to the the the
the this wall of TVs behind me is 7 feet
tall and 24t wide with islands in the
front for the cross shuts there's even
more just the wall of TVs behind me
weighs more than 1.5 metric tons and
every single one of the TVs comprising
that wall totally works and will be
displaying images and videos while like
the it's all going on it's pretty epic
dude it's unbelievably epic yeah like I
I I can't even stand it it's just like
every little piece of this
show like we've gone to like ridiculous
lengths to make it like just overly
ambitious like I mean I dare say that
this special is actually special I'm so
stoked for it yeah I me and the best
part too is it's funny it's funny like
with or without the TVs with or without
like all the kind of bells and whistles
like it's so damn funny so this is just
icing on the cake I mean dude and you
have the same director like same people
are shooting it that did AR special so
that's cool too right um I've been
working on this bucket list show for
more than five years I mean that's
insane of course like during the
pandemic not a lot was was was going on
so maybe call it three and a half but I
spent eight months just putting the
basic show together with the the first
vignettes and then I mean dude we it's
just and it's never stopped like the the
the evolution the work on it kicking out
bits replacing them with new and better
ones like the videos get like changed
every night almost like with little tiny
things D how do you feel that it's
almost the end of The Bucket List tour
Bittersweet I mean there's there's just
about nowhere to go left with it I mean
granted we didn't do Europe and that
kind of is a kick in the nuts but um
it's time it's time and and I I feel so
so ready man so ready for this for this
taping and then once that happens we've
got like what I what I call the Victory
lap we've got the one last run down the
the East Coast um in September and then
it's on to the next thing yeah and how's
that going to work like are you going to
go back to like clubs and like workout
material like cuz you're sort of a
different animal than most comedians cuz
you do like a multimedia thing but you
you plan to do something like that that
I mean the way that I did The Bucket
List was to first film The vignette and
then go to the comedy club and just tell
the story of that vignette and so I put
together piece by piece when when you go
on stage at a comedy club in La you
typically
get like a a 10 minute set maybe 20 but
like 10 15 minutes and and that would be
my time to just tell the story of one
bit and then you know I would like I
would work that and I'd work that like
over without showing the video without
showing the video oh no video oh so you
just tell the story and you just got to
make it funny even without the payoff of
seeing it right if I was at the
Hollywood improv I would be able to show
the video but if I was at the comedy
store or the laugh Factory I would not
be able to show the video it's better
that you can't cuz like you have to make
it funny without it yeah it's totally
better that you can't wow that's cool
and so that that that's absolutely what
I'll do with the next one um but it's
just it's yeah it's crazy like whatever
happens after this it's it's it's one of
two things that I'm going to go into uh
of course one being gone too far and the
other one like this is kind of uh I mean
who knows if if it'll happen yeah but
what whatever comes next it is
so high level that um it's just exciting
and I'm not like sad about going into it
I'm nervous because the bucket list is
so good MH but that's good fear that's
like the fear you need like yeah do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is sto's butt wipes for your butth
hole are available on Amazon and if you
want a real bundle of a deal you can get
sto's hot sauce for your butthole plus
sto's butthole destroyer and sto's butt
wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude